[Music]
okay everyone i'm really excited today
to be
joined with you to talk about the
handmaid's tale it's been almost
two years i've been dying to get back to
this grind of covering the show it's one
of my favorite shows
of all time and it's deep meaning to me
because this is really the show that
helped me
get on the map with reviews so i'm just
happy to be back
praise be so this is my review spoiler
review
of episode one of season four pigs now
this episode was directed by
colin watkinson it's the second episode
he's ever directed the show
but he's also done most of the
cinematography for the show
and it's written by the one and only
bruce miller the showrunner of the show
i'm first going to cover the main plot
with
june and then we'll go to what's going
on with lawrence the waterfords and
lydia so what's interesting is it jumps
in right where we left off at the end of
season three with june here being
carried by the other handmaids
and you see they open with her thinking
about this happy music
and that she's in like this dreamlight
state that's this state
you get in where it's like she's near
death here she's
kind of almost accepting she's gonna die
but she snapped out of that when
they are tending to her brutal wounds
now this episode has a lot of vibes of a
horror film it comes from the score
which i loved in this episode because
it was already showing you that this
season the handmaid's tale was going to
feel way more fresh than
the previous season that it was trying
new things and that the score wasn't
repeating
the same tunes we know from handmaid's
doing something a little different here
which i really liked and made
for a very eerie atmosphere but that
also comes to
how they film certain scenes and i love
the tension built just in the scene from
the start
with the handmaids and they're in this
guardian's truck escaping and they're
in the floorboards here and we see the
boot of this guardian that's
just one they can't trust it feels so
tense that they have to be quiet it's
like something you would see in any of
the holocaust films we've seen made in
hollywood before you get these 10 scenes
of just hiding from someone
who is looking to destroy your type of
person
and what this show always does so well
is its bread and butter is its
cinematography
and you see this when june gets to this
safe house
but first checks it's the right one to
see if the guy has the lantern they're
looking for
but it's in that classic handmaid's cold
color palette here
and we get these beautiful wide shots
and this fog coming in again to add to
the eeriness
of what's really going on in this
episode in this new location which i
appreciate it
and what it does so well in a show
that's going to go for multiple seasons
is it does a great thing you should do
and especially like a season four is
introduce
interesting new characters and
interesting new setting which they do
here with the setting
with the farm but also with the new
character here of
esther and you see when june's now faint
and she's puking and it's getting this
perspective of her where everything's
dizzy to her when she gets into the safe
house
that's where we actually meet esther
played by the brilliant mckenna grace
who is just a child actor
totally on the rise she's landing a lot
of roles you might know her from
haunting a phil house
and like i'm saying about the horror
vibes you get that here where she's like
you're the one i've been waiting for
i had dreams we were killing people
together wonderful dreams so those lines
are huge
and what's so great about the writing in
this episode is that you're getting
payoffs
in stuff that's built in this episode
everything has a point to it every line
has a point to it
and thematically it just works great in
just
one story in this one episode and
why those lines of esks are so powerful
about
dreams of you and people we're killing
together is it really hits home june's
legacy now
that word has gotten out about this
rebel she's like this legend already for
the resistance to gilead
and it plays so well because really what
it is is that
she's having dreams with june because
june is just her only hope she has left
here in her
horrible life she's been given and it
shows the
power of june's just what she's done
to help people around her but people
from afar that affected how it just
goes across boundaries so we'll get more
into that when we learn more about
esther's character but we go the next
day where jun wakes up in the morning
and she's actually talking about
her physical state and that her body
isn't what it used to be where she could
just give it a command and it will do it
right this is the narration she's having
in her head that i think everybody will
have in their life when they hit their
30s
it's besides her having this wound she's
just
not only been mentally drained as a show
has gone on for everything she's had to
do
but it's taking a physical toll on her
and that also has to do with
leadership right being a leader being
the one who has to make
really hard decisions it weighs down on
you and that's going to be a theme in
this episode it also is going to connect
to lydia
and her being someone who's had to be a
leader
and how it's physically taking a toll on
her as well which we'll also get into
but there's a great line with june here
where she's like
my world can't be small because she's
talking about it's small in that moment
in this room because
others need me to protect them she's
like gilead keeps coming
they're always going to keep looking for
them it will never end and that
she really is this character we love and
she's a hero because she has no time to
rest and she knows what it takes to stop
these villains and that to be this
successful leader and survive in this
world you have to
just keep going even as much as you're
suffering now it's cool to see all the
handmaids now they're like
working on this farm but what made me
really smile as june smiles is seeing
janine with the pig mr darcy that was
just made me so happy like i would love
to just see janine with that pig in a
spin-off series it's just so great but
in these moments of joy
you see that again it's reaffirmed just
showing and not just telling how they
can't rest where alma has to literally
have binoculars
out on the outskirts of this farm to
always be watching they always have to
be watching their back
and they even have a line here where
esther mentions worrying about drones
watching them but what's so
interesting about this character of mrs
keys
is that we're seeing the culture that we
know of serena joy of the wives kind of
passed down and how that would affect
younger wives and how they
grow up as an adult and she's smoking
the cigarette here at
14 years old and she's very uptight
right
and it's so great to watch lizzie moss
as an actress because she's so good at
just reactions
and just the way she's reacting to
esther at first
is like really just great because
esther's coming in hot here you know
she's a june super fan she's excited but
she's like
come on let's go take out gilead right
now and june's like
relax you know i just got here and i
wound it but we're getting lines that
are set up here to get huge payoff which
is just
excellent excellent writing and that's
here when
miss keys says where mayday and why did
you even come here if you weren't going
to fight so that will wrap around to the
end of the episode now
what also works is the title of this
episode being pigs because we see now
janine
sadly goes and says a prayer over mr
darcy the pig and it's going to be shot
and eaten but
what it's really talking about with pigs
is the pigs we're gonna learn about
that are these men that raped
esther but what works is how they reveal
that
and that twist about what really
happened
to esther and why she's the way she is
because we see she's really hard on
janine
and jun sees that as like look you know
these women have been through hell i
mean she literally had her
eye taken out and you're yelling at her
about not eating this pig
and what it brings out in esther is she
gets to tell her story to june like hey
you know handmaid's had it rough but so
did
wives like me and it's interesting
because this story that
esther shares is actually very similar
to the real life story that happened
in the netflix documentary it's a really
good documentary the keepers
where it's this really sad story not
just about someone
attacking someone of youth but bringing
in other men to do it and it's like
passed around it's really hard to listen
to and hear it's so
sad and tragic but what it does is it
really is a wake-up call for june in
this episode that
this stuff is still happening it's
happening worse than you can even
imagine
and that they do need to fight and that
this is a world we're in and
she says this line none of this is your
fault none of it which will be also
said to alma later on and it's june
reminding herself in a way like
everything even we do to each other as
women here and if we're hard on each
other whatever
again you have to remember none of this
is our fault we have to really address
the true problem here which is these
men in power and gilead just a sign i
think god is just i think god's gonna
make them pay
and again this is where you're starting
to reveal how awesome this writing is
and how
this effect of this new character miss
keys was just affected by june
the thought of this woman being out
there this rebel this hope
really powerful stuff but you see once
june steps out of that barn
with esther she's kind of settling into
this evil again this reality
of what this world is like and is angry
and you know that
perfectly mixes into her seeing now alma
who's kind of chillax about everything
and she's like alma we're not
free and do your babysitting duties
basically of watching
esther because she's protecting us but
man alma was even saucy here
saying you know don't yell at me we
carried your fat ass i was like whoa
but this leads into this really powerful
moment because
june goes to the barn and sees now alma
and janine are dancing everyone's having
a good time
and it's a breath of fresh air for them
and they're enjoying life for once in
this horrible world they're in but
it's a reminder to june like why it's
all worth it to do what she does and
breaks her back for
everybody because it got them that
moment those beautiful moments in this
world so it
makes it all worth it for her and it
also shows you that theme of like being
a leader
she's not necessarily the one who gets
to take a breath and have those moments
but
still knowing that when she's
sacrificing moments she's giving it to
others which again motivates her to keep
going so
what's intriguing is that esther left
this knife out in the kitchen right
so jew notices this and that's when mr
keys walks in this
messed up commander who did this stuff
to esther and had other men do it but
what's intriguing about this commander
is like it seems like he's not all there
right he's banging his cane when we
first seen him
and he's kind of like talking about
esther like he's just noticing her in a
way so
that's why esther is able to pull off
what she's pulling off right now with
these
guardians that are actually good
guardians with her protecting her
and the handmaids and that this guy's
just so out of it he doesn't even really
know what's going on but what sets june
off is him mentioning oh yeah esther
that pretty girl it's just like creepy
vibes and she was about to
basically slit this guy's throat until
that guardian walked in
because what happens is this actual
guardian that was
involved with what happened to esther
shows up johnny and he caught on to
these handmaids there so they gotta
capture them and when june puts two and
two together that it was one of the men
that hurt esther it's decision making
time again as a leader here like what do
we do with this guy
how are we gonna handle this right and
it goes to those great out-of-focus
shots
of june where she's feeling anxious and
it
really just little moments here of
physicality being that struggle she's
been having
because this guy johnny like runs over
her and she falls down and then
you know the other handmaids start
beating him to a pulp but she it's
it's really interesting to watch june
because she's got such leadership
and they trust her and everything
because she's literally like stop and
then they stop
but she's like let's take him to the bar
and so i'm talking about how we get that
line again where she's like it's not
your fault to alma cause alma feels bad
she wasn't keeping a better eye
on esther but alma man she's just
winging it here gotta babysit come on
but june's just reflecting now with this
dark story that this little girl or
family center here to be passed around
and raped just horrible stuff but
jun's like this man betrayed his country
and she's talking about the united
states not gilead and that he raped a
child
repeatedly and punishment for his crimes
is death
this is like what lawrence will say
later on the tao of june this is the way
of june this is
her law and her justice and you get your
payoff i'm talking about where june says
esther you were right we are mayday we
don't hide we fight and in this place we
all fight which is a huge line because
then she hands the knife to esther this
is important because it's
june's way of how we're seeing she would
probably raise hannah in this world
and giving that knife to esther she
knows this is part of surviving now
like yeah even you as a child here need
to learn how to be capable of doing
something like this
and it's also payoff in setup because of
her
foreshadowing this when esther said in
the beginning of the episode she had
this dream of killing people with june
and we're seeing it happen here and
we're seeing one of these
pigs being killed the true pigs not the
pigs
like mr darcy and we see now june goes
to her bed
exhausted physically exhausted she has
this wound but she's just
everything's taken a toll on her but
she's gonna keep fighting and going and
props to elizabeth moss this is why
she's such a great actor she always
gives 110
but that's also shown here the whole
episode she's physically performing this
to a t she doesn't let up on
having that physical struggle come off
on her but esther comes into the beds
like i love you
and she says i love you too banana
obviously it's a throw to hannah here
and that that's this relationship she
has with esther now it's like a real
life daughter for her and for esther
it's like a real like mother figure so
now let's go to the b plot to this
episode first we see actually the
waterford it's amazing and hysterical to
see serena complain about her rights
here come on now what a hypocrite
and she's trying to smoke inside but
what's important is mark
informs serena and fred about the 86
children
that were taken out of gilead and fred
says line this will start a war so
what i really like this episode does is
it's putting our villains back in the
villain roles meaning
they're all out now to get june they're
pissed this is something
that makes sense that would set gilead
off because it's the children they lost
that they
value so much in their culture right so
this happens here with fred
and they do a great job because now we
go to lydia's story
lydia's pride's really hit right this
council
of gileads saying those children are
taken
under females that were under your
charge she's not being put on her for
their discipline but
really dissed here when they said they
kind of blame it on her fragility and
they say
handmade sinful [ __ ] more trouble than
their worth where lydia doesn't like to
hear that because again
she takes pride in her handmaids and she
doesn't see them like that
but she's like no they're not it's
really they were misled by one
really bad handmaid and that again sets
up for lydia now
to really want to have june put on the
wall here and says
finder and bring her to me so again it's
just this great setup of these og
villains you had in the show now
kind of make it more interesting
conflict where i did like where they're
making them more gray in previous
seasons but
right now it feels right for them to be
kind of back in the role of
being pissed about these children being
taken because it will make it more
interesting for the bee
plots to have it that they're kind of
all just on a mission to get
june just more intense conflict and
what's brilliant is that
these writers and creators of the show
listened to the fans they brought nick
back
who's much needed because he's an og
character again
i don't know why i'm saying og so much
but i feel like saying it and
having him come back is important
because we're attached to that character
with
him in june's relationship and he's
mysterious now right so he's directly
brought into where lawrence is being
held in gilead
and he's on trial but we get a misdirect
of what's gonna happen to lawrence or at
first we think
he's probably gonna be killed here for
what he did but really
nick is still on the june path
because he got lawrence to basically be
able to survive and now they're just
going to use him as council for these
invasion plans on canada because
lawrence knows how bad that can be
because that's just a full-on war that's
going to cause
and he's like do you want that to be
june's legacy has she started a war
that caused more death but instead let's
do
something the right way here for june
and make it worth it that these kids
were taken out
my only qualm with this though was i'm
not fully convinced and would have liked
a better
explanation on how the hell nick talked
the council out
of keeping lawrence from getting killed
here
because this guy was conspiring with the
person they're all the most mad at for
taking out their children
so i'm just curious how that was sold
that we're going to keep this guy alive
and honestly i'm a little over the
character of lawrence i'm a little over
him in his quips
and i think he to me is a one season
character
and i'm not sure i want to see a bunch
of screen time with him right now as a
advisor to the council
i just think he's kind of just too on
the nose of a character at this point of
what's just
and what should be done and he's a
humorous character but
i'm over it now i'm time to move on for
me from lawrence that's a personal
opinion of mine but
so be it i think a lot of people like
them but man this episode
i am so happy that this episode was so
good and that it's back to form i think
this was actually
better than any episode in season three
because it went back to good
storytelling instead of trying to get
too
focused on being like cinematic and
exciting and just
actually focusing on what made the show
great in the first place which was great
great storytelling writing making you
feel great emotions
while keeping great cinematography and
great acting all around
and it did a great thing here being a
season four of a show now
introducing a new interesting new
character in
esther and again having a new setting
here on this farm which i actually dug i
think
everything here felt fresh which is what
the show needs to do it needs to keep
fresh where i think season three
we were all starting to feel a little
drained of the format we're used to of
handmaid's tale and
the world we're in and what we're around
and this felt more expanding now and
more character growth because it's
the june we know and love but she's
getting older now and
not in the sense of age more in the
sense of you're aging quicker
and the amount of stress this woman is
taking on to survive so i think the
stakes have been raised and
the interest here is really strong and
it's just a good hero
fighting against really strong forces of
gilead so we'll see where this all goes
but i'm giving this one a 9.4
let me know down below what you thought
of this episode obviously all three
episodes are out now
i have reviewed episode two and three as
well so you can check those out they'll
be linked down below and at the end of
this video
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of the
handmaid's tale i also do celebrity
interviews
and if you really like what i do here
you can donate two dollars a month
to a monthly donation link down below
for paypal i'll be forever grateful
it will be able to give me the needs
necessary to do this full time one day
and make more videos for you guys
and please follow me at steve barley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time